c'est ainsi qu'un sujet que c'est
extrêmement basses alors c'est pas ce
que j'ai nouveau parce que l'un de
l'autre on a tous voulu découvrir aller
voir les magazines un peu coquin
chercher les cassettes mois père je
voulais raconter ces sources vous avez
dit on aux gars merci mon sens c'est
bien qu'ils aient des cassettes de vos
grands pères mais il y avait une
démarche n'était pas accessible c'est
tellement qu'il était était un ado bref
là le problème c'est que tout le monde a
accès c'est facile
alors est ce que ça vous choque est-ce
que qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
quand est ce qu'on peut faire changer
les choses
on va demander à belleville ben moi je
pense sincèrement que qu'aujourd'hui les
résultats qu'il fallait les chiffres qui
sont ses vrais ça alarmant que chez ces
jeunes ça n'est un peu de la frustration
benjamin parce que ça risque d'être des
sujets qui sont tellement tabou dont on
parle pas nécessairement peut-être à la
maison n'osent pas aborder la sexualité
avec ses enfants a expliqué comment on
fait comment ça se passe
ce qu'il faut faire à quel âge commencer
et c'est mieux et accompagner nos
enfants à l'école et des cours
d'éducation sexuelle ça arrive chez les
adolescents effectivement autour de deux
cadres de la 4e 3e et ça rentre pas dans
le fond des choses si j'ose ce jeu non
pardon non c'est non mais c'est vrai et
je pense que ça n'est vraiment de vous
de la frustration des jeunes et comme
vous l'avez dit à l'époque qu'il avait
pas internet mais ont piqué les
magazines des parents on en retrouvait
sous sous sous les matelas et tout mais
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'avec qu'avec
le téléphone c'est très dangereux je
pense qu'ils sont véritablement
accompagner les jeunes et que les
parents s'investissent et des moyens de
verrouiller tout ça on part de la
reconnaissance faciale maintenant il ya
la ja l'empreinte des états d'âme et
n'atteint que ça soit en tant que ça à
pornic saint michel vous avez une fille
que les grands maintenant qui est grand
oui bien sûr même s'il passe le bac se
tenait bon et vous voulez mais je ne
surveille pas parce qu'on ne peut pas
être derrière ces enfants faisant les
enfants savent très bien que les enfants
matt ont tellement nos moyens avec leur
téléphone avec une tablette avec
l'ordinateur de faire ce qu'ils veulent
que j'ai abandonné depuis bien longtemps
duration la pression ils n'ont pas
l'intention d'aller sur ce site là à 18
ans comment elle est mal à 18 ans et un
majeur et bien sûr mais même eux
venaient d'enfants qui jouent alors ils
ne sont pas en âge de deux de ses trois
enfants et drôle c'est que magali vous
savez c'est là c'est la reine d'aidés
bilatérales étaient allés son téléphone
il sait pas qu'il est greffé dans
l'arrêté qui est dense
et c'est ses enfants c'est
paradoxalement pas portables et il n'y
en aura pas avant parce que je connais
justement les deux réseaux sociaux je
suis bien placé pour le connaître c'est
dramatique c'est dramatique à tous les
niveaux moi je pense que en dessous de
16 ans il faut bloquer les téléphones
pour les jeunes mais comment pelé le
clic c'est parce que les réseaux sociaux
c'est facile tout est facile dans les
rayons peut pas si tu laisses en fait un
téléphone à un enfant c'est fini il a
accès à tous les peuples tout faire ils
sont très intelligents les enfants
beaucoup plus intelligent que ce qu'on
peut penser et ils trouvent ils
trouveront en face on est bien sûr elle
a filé copains ma chérie et c'est non
mais même limite ça veut dire que même
s'il trouve on peut toujours tout faire
dans la vie mais si on contrôler si les
parents sont derrière elle mais tu peux
qu'adhérer solution au lit mais si tu ne
peux pas chérie j'ai mangé que non il
faut mettre des barrières et c'est tout
le monde fait un effort tu sais amont
donner un accès facile de dire tu
trouves c'est pas grave alors je laisse
faire ça si ça avec son objet